[MUSIC PLAYING]
AANAND IYER: All right,
good morning, everyone.
So in this session, we'll
talk about Kubeflow Pipelines
and how it can help you
accelerate development
of production machine
learning applications.
My name is Aanand Iyer, and I am
a product manager in the Google
Cloud AI platform team.
We're very fortunate to
have, as my co-presenter,
Willem Pienaar from GOJEK.
GOJEK is a fast-growing
customer of Google Cloud,
and William is a lead
data scientist at GOJEK.
And he'll talk about how
they're leveraged Kubeflow
Pipelines for a real-world
production machine learning
use case.
For the first 20
minutes or so, I'll
give you an overview
of Kubeflow Pipelines,
and then I'll hand
things over to Willem
for the more interesting part
of the presentation, which
includes a demo.
Towards the very end, we
will have a Q&A session.
We'll be taking questions
from all of you.
And in fact, while the
session is going on,
you can start adding your
questions to the Dory Q&A app.
I'll give you a couple
seconds to actually
quickly look at the instructions
for adding questions
to the Dory app.
All right.
With that, let's get started.
So first, let me start with
the motivation behind Kubeflow
Pipelines.
Why did we start this
project in the first place?
We started this project
because building and deploying
real-world machine
learning applications
is hard and costly because
of the lack of tooling
for the end-to-end development
and deployment lifecycle,
or the end-to-end process.
Let me elaborate on
that a little bit.
Often, when we talk about
building a machine learning
application, we're talking
about developing the core model.
And the model
development happens
with libraries like TensorFlow
and Python, Scikit-learn,
XGBoost, and so forth.
So often, we talk about
developing the model
and then deploying the model.
And, yes, absolutely, that
is at the heart of developing
a machine learning application.
But when you are
building, deploying,
and running a machine learning
application in production,
that entails many other stages.
A production machine
learning application
is often running continuously.
It's running 24/7 by 365.
Data is coming in
on a regular basis,
either streaming in or
coming in as batches
on periodic intervals.
Models have to be constantly
updated and improved
upon and deployed.
And of course, before you
deploy any newly-trained model,
you have to make sure the new
models are safe for deployment.
For the data that
is streaming in,
you have to do data
pre-processing and data
validation and make sure
that there are no data
quality issues.
Then, after that, you do
featured engineering followed
by model training with
hyperparameter tuning,
followed by model validation
and so on and so forth.
So what is needed
is simple tooling
to orchestrate and manage these
multi-phase machine learning
workflows, and the ability
to run them reliably
and repeatedly.
And that is the problem
that Kubeflow Pipelines
aims to solve.
So actually, before
we move on, I
should call out
that this diagram.
It's not a new
diagram we created.
It's actually from a
fairly seminal Google paper
that was authored a few
years back that talks
about the hidden debt in
building machine learning
applications.
So actually, I would like to
have a quick show of hands
to see if folks have
actually seen this diagram
or something similar before.
So please raise your
hands if you've seen it.
All right, wow.
That's actually
quite a few of you.
So possibly, I am preaching
to the choir here,
but that's awesome.
All right, so before we get
into the specifics of Kubeflow
Pipelines, I want to provide
a little bit more context.
Kubeflow Pipelines is part
of the open source Kubeflow
project.
Open source Kubeflow is
a seamlessly integrated
collection of tools and
services for the full production
machine learning lifecycle.
Everything from distributed,
scalable model training
to deploying models for
online serving at scale,
to notebooks with
Jupyter hub, and then
workflow orchestration
and metadata
and workflow management
with Kubeflow Pipelines,
and so on and so forth.
So Kubeflow Pipelines is a
part of this larger open source
project called Kubeflow.
Kubeflow services are built
to run on top of Kubernetes.
And we chose Kubernetes
as the underlying platform
because, at this
point, Kubernetes
is almost a de facto for
anything that entails
cluster compute at scale.
So Kubernetes provides
the scalability,
and it also enables
hybrid deployments
because Kubeflow flow can run
on any Kubernetes cluster.
So that cluster can be
running on Google Cloud
or it can be running on-prem,
or multiple other clouds.
And of course, with
the Anthos announcement
made two days back,
you can actually
run Google on top
of Anthos and help
Anthos manage these deployments
in multiple environments.
And of course, on
Google Cloud, Kubeflow
is easy to deploy with Google
Kubernetes Engine or Anthos.
And in many cases, for
applications authored
with the Kubeflow
SDKs, you can run them
on fully-managed services
in the Cloud AI platform.
So I wanted to provide
that bit of context
before we dove into the
specifics of Kubeflow
Pipelines.
Now, the capabilities
provided by Kubeflow Pipelines
can largely be put
under three buckets--
machine learning
workflow orchestration,
sharing reusability
and easy composability,
and rapid, reliable
experimentation.
So let's start with the
first one, machine learning
workflow orchestration.
To make things more
concrete, let's look
at a screenshot of
a workflow that was
run with Kubeflow Pipelines.
So for any workflow that you
run with Kubeflow Pipelines,
you get this rich
visual depiction
of the topology
of the workflows.
So you can see that and
understand what was run.
Of course, this is just
an illustrative machine
learning workflow.
Of course, when you build your
own machine learning workflows,
you can have all sorts
of different topologies.
For a given step
of the workflow,
you can use your own tools
and libraries of choice.
A given step of the workflow can
be a single-node instance that
can run with different types
of hardware, GPUs and TPUs,
or it can also be--
a given step can
be something that
runs in a distributed fashion.
So long story short, this is
just an illustrative workflow.
And of course, you
can build all sorts
of interesting topologies and
applications and architectures.
Now, let's look at
this specific example.
In this particular
example-- just
to make things more concrete--
this particular example,
it starts with a data
pre-processing and data
validation step followed by
a feature engineering step.
And after that,
we're forking out
and training three different
kinds of models in parallel.
And each of these
model training nodes
encapsulates hyperparameter
tuning within it.
Then, after that, we
take the best models
trained in each of these forks
and run them on a test data set
and analyze them and
compare them and then pick
the best model.
And if that model happens to
meet our performance threshold,
we can deploy it to an
online serving endpoint.
So that is an
example of the type
of workflows you can build and
deploy with Kubeflow Pipelines.
For each step of the
workflow, you actually
have access to all the
relevant metadata and metrics
at your fingertips.
So, as an example, let's
take the training step.
If it produced an
auto c-curve, you
can visualize it right there.
Or if it produced the
rich metadata that
can be visualized
through TensorBoard,
TensorBoard is just
one click away.
So long story short, all
the relevant information
that you need is available
right there at your fingertips.
For each step of
the workflow, you
have access to the configuration
parameters that were passed in,
and you can also see what
were the inputs to that step
and what were the
outputs produced.
So for any module trained
with Kubeflow Pipelines,
you will not have
to wonder, or you
won't have the problem of
not being able to answer
how that model was produced.
Because for any model trained
with Kubeflow Pipelines,
you can go back to the
corresponding execution run
and you have all the relevant
information at your fingertips.
And this is particularly
important for production
machine learning workflows.
So now, let's take a
peek under the hood
and let's try to understand what
exactly constitutes a Kubeflow
Pipeline.
So Kubeflow Pipeline
consists of multiple steps,
and each step of the
Kubeflow Pipeline
is a containerized task.
We're talking about production
machine learning workflows,
and containers are the
industry standard solution
for portability,
for repeatability,
and encapsulation
of dependencies.
So we don't want to
reinvent the wheel.
That's why we built a solution
that leverages containers
at the heart of it.
And of course, because this
gets deployed on Kubernetes,
of course we were going
to choose containers.
Now, as I mentioned previously,
each step of the workflow
can be very
heterogeneous, can run
on different types of hardware.
It can be a simple Python
script or something that
runs in a distributed fashion.
It can be an Apache Spark job,
or it could be a distributed
model training job.
Steps of the workflow
can also call out
to other Google services.
So those are the
steps of the workflow.
Now, the other key
aspect of the workflow
is definition of the
sequence, or the topology
of the workflow.
The sequence in which
the steps should run
and how the data flows
between these steps,
how to connect
the outputs of one
step with the inputs
of downstream steps.
And then, the third aspect
of defining a pipeline
is defining the set
of input parameters
that the end user
has to provide.
So the containerized
steps, or each step
packaged as a container, the
definition of the workflow
topology, and the specification
of the input parameters
together constitute
a Kubeflow Pipeline.
So now, let's see how you
author a Kubeflow Pipeline.
When we spoke to the target
audience-- data scientists,
machine learning engineers,
and machine learning
practitioners-- time
and again, everyone
said Python is their
preferred lingua franca.
So we said, OK, let's
provide an SDK that
is fairly intuitive and
native to Python coders.
So that's what we have provided.
You get a fairly
intuitive Python SDK
that you use to specify the
topology of your workflow.
And specifying
the topology, it's
basically as simple as calling
Python functions that represent
the various steps
of your workflow
and connecting them
with inputs and outputs.
I won't go into too many
details of the Python SDK
and, actually, in the
next section of the talk,
Willem, as he's doing his
demo, will provide more details
about the SDK.
And of course, the SDK is a
broad topic in and of itself.
So I'd request you to look
at the Kubeflow Pipelines
documentation to learn
more about the SDK.
Now, at this point, you may be
wondering, but wait a minute,
I said each step of the workflow
is a containerized task.
And here I am talking
about defining the workflow
with a Python SDK and calling
the steps Python functions.
So, there's some
disconnect here.
Valid observation.
In its simplest form--
because we're
orchestrating containers--
as long as the containers
follow a protocol
on how they accept inputs
and how they produce outputs,
any containerized task can be
converted into a workflow step.
And so that provides
flexibility.
In fact, we have a
customer that has
taken Fortran libraries
that do numerical analysis,
put them in a
container, and called
that particular container as
a task in a Kubeflow workflow.
So this provides a lot of
flexibility, the ability
to take a containerized
task and convert it
into a separate workflow.
And the way you do that is
you define a Python function
wrapper for that container
by invoking this SDK function
called the container ops.
You call the
container op and you
convert the Python
wrapper function
that you can now
use while you're
defining the workflow topology.
But we realized that our target
audience-- data scientists
and machine learning
practitioners--
they don't come in
and build docker
containers on a daily basis.
Rather, they're not
directly dealing
with docker on a daily basis.
And in many cases,
for the most part--
and we'll continue to
improve upon this--
for the most part,
the dockerization
becomes an
implementation detail.
So if you're writing a step
of the workflow with Python,
we provide simple utilities
and function decorators
to take your Python code and
package it up automatically
as a containerized
task that you can
call as a step of the workflow.
So a key aspect here is
while, under the hood,
each task is a container,
for the most part,
machine learning practitioners
and data scientists
will deal with their
Python code and we
take care of the mechanics
of dockerization.
We simplify the
dockerization for you.
And of course, if you're
running it on Google Cloud,
you are going to
call and leverage
Google Cloud's amazing
fully-managed solutions
for data analytics
and machine learning
model training and so forth.
And for these services, we give
you out-of-the-box connectors.
So again, you don't have
to focus on the mechanics
of calling out these services.
We simplify that for you.
You focus on your code and
you use these out-of-the-box
connectors.
And of course, we will continue
to improve upon this stuff.
All right.
So now, let's look at the
second key value proposition
of Kubeflow Pipelines,
which is sharing
reusability and composability.
And the key premise here is most
machine learning applications
today, they're built as
bespoke applications.
But as machine learning
becomes more mainstream,
it becomes a key aspect of--
it goes mainstream.
It's a key aspect embedded
into multiple applications.
You need a faster way to build
machine learning applications,
and the best way to
do that is the ability
to reuse the great work
that others have done.
You don't want to always
start from scratch.
If someone else has
built an amazing workflow
or an amazing
component that can be
used as a part of the workflow,
we want to enable that.
We want you to be able to find
it easily, quickly, reuse it,
and you're good to go.
And, of course, you'll customize
it for your specific needs.
So with Kubeflow Pipelines, once
you've defined the workflow,
you can package it
up as a zip file.
And that zip file can
be shared with others,
and they can run it on
their own Kubeflow cluster.
And because each task
is containerized,
you're not worried
about the portability.
So package up your Kubeflow
Pipeline as a zip file
and give it to--
let's just say you develop the
workflow on your development
cluster and you've
tested it it looks good.
And you want to hand it
off to the production
team that will deploy it
on the production cluster.
Great, just package
it up as a zip file
and hand it over to them.
And often, what you want to
do is, if you're working,
say, in a large
organization or you're
part of a broader
community, you want
to build an amazing application
and share it with others
so that they can leverage it
and run it and build upon it.
So, if I were to find a Kubeflow
application packaged as a zip
file from someone
else, I can load it up
in my Kubeflow cluster,
and I will get this UI--
a UI form that is automatically
created based on the inputs
accepted by that pipeline.
I'll get that UI form
and, without having
to write too much
code, I can actually
fill in the parameters
of the UI form
and I can try out a Kubeflow
application very easily.
So that's a key aspect of
being able to reuse and quickly
try out the work that
someone else has done.
And this reusability is not
just for full end-to-end machine
learning workflows or
a complete pipeline.
We've actually made it such
that an individual step
of a workflow can be packaged
up as a reusable component.
So let's just say you're doing
some very interesting feature
engineering, or you've come
up with a very interesting way
to do model analysis
that you want everyone
within your
organization to follow.
Well, great.
Author that as a usable
Kubeflow Pipeline component
and they can use it easily
within their own custom
workflows.
And because we're talking
about reuse and share,
I have to give a
shout-out to the AI Hub.
It's a product we launched
publicly yesterday,
and the AI Hub is your one-stop
shop for sharing and discovery
of relevant machine
learning assets.
It has multiple types of machine
learning assets, from models
to notebooks and so forth.
And of course, a noteworthy
category of assets in AI Hub
will be Kubeflow Pipelines and
Kubeflow Pipeline components.
And just to make
things more concrete,
I want to give you an
example of how easy it
is to find a reusable
component in the AI hub
and use it as a part of your own
custom machine learning, custom
Kubeflow Pipeline.
It literally is a
couple lines of code.
So, you first start with this
lowered component statement.
You go to the AI Hub, you find
your Kubeflow Pipeline usable
component.
There'll be a Copy URL button.
You hit the Copy URL
button, you get that URL.
You then use it in this
load component statement
and you get the Python function
representation of that step.
And now you can use that step
as a part of your workflow
when you're defining
your workflow.
So long story short,
this whole aspect
of reusing the great work
that others have done,
or if you've done
great work, being
able to share that with others
is a key aspect of Kubeflow
Pipelines, in conjunction
with AI Hub aims to enable.
And that's a key
aspect of scaling out
production machine learning.
Now, let's talk about the
third key value proposition
of Kubeflow Pipelines.
And to motivate
this, I actually want
to call out a quote from one
of the winners of the latest
gaggle 1 million
prize competition.
So one of the members of the
team that won the competition
said that for every
idea that worked,
they tried 100
ideas that failed.
And that is the nature of
production machine learning.
It's an applied science.
You have to try
many different ideas
to find the ones that
would work on your data
for your application.
So, long story short,
we want to make it easy
for you to rapidly
iterate on your ideas,
but do so in a reliable
and manageable way.
So, for any workflow
or pipeline that
is run on the Kubeflow
Pipelines environment--
on a Kubeflow cluster--
you get the full historical view
of all the prior runs, as well
as your current runs.
Not only that, you actually
have filtering and search
functionality to
quickly find a past run.
And once you find a past run
that you're interested in,
of course, you'll have all the
relevant metrics and metadata,
config parameters, and so
forth at your fingertips.
And then, you can
hit the Clone button
and create a clone
of that workflow
and just run that
clone if you just
want to repeat a prior
experimental run,
or you can clone it.
You'll get the UI form that
shows all the input parameters,
and you can tweak
the input parameters
and launch a slightly different
variant of this workflow
to try a different idea.
So we've made it very easy
to hit the Clone button,
tweak the variant with different
configuration parameters,
and run it.
And in the future,
we'll actually
extend that to enable
rapid iteration
with the code pertaining to a
specific step of the workflow
as well.
So right now, you can
do rapid iteration
with configuration parameter
changes and, in the future,
we want to enable that
for code changes as well.
So, at this point, you've
done rapid iteration.
You've launched many different
variants of your workflow
to see what works best for
your data, for your use case.
So let's just say
you have 20, 30,
or more different executions.
Of course, most of those
are actually going to fail.
Not every execution is going to
result in the desired metrics.
So now you have this
long list of experiments.
And in the List view of
these experimental runs,
you get to see the
most important metrics
right there in the list view.
So if you've got, say,
20, 30 different execution
runs, you can quickly
hone in on the ones that
performed well or produced
interesting results
and ignore the ones
that didn't perform well
or didn't have
interesting results.
Select the ones that
are interesting.
Select a subset of experiments
that are interesting.
And then hit the
Compare Runs button
to get a side-by-side comparison
of these execution runs.
And you can do a
side-by-side comparison
of the different config
parameters and metrics
and so on and so forth.
So you can quickly
hone in on what
was different about
these executional runs.
You can quickly hone in on
the technique or the idea that
led to interesting results.
So that's how we enable rapid,
reliable experimentation.
It's reliable
because the workflow
itself is backed by containers,
which can be run repeatedly.
All your relevant config
parameters and metrics
are right there at
your fingertips.
All right.
So those were the key
features of Kubeflow Pipelines
that I wanted to
provide as an overview.
I do want to mention that we
have quite a few customers
using Kubeflow Pipelines.
We have Descartes Labs.
And it's possible some
of you actually caught
their presentation, I
think, two days back.
They use it for interesting
work on satellite images.
We also have Carousell,
an e-commerce company,
using it for ranking of
images and scoring images
and tagging them with relevant
metadata and so forth.
We have Baker Hughes
using Kubeflow pipelines
for workflows on
industrial data--
metrics collected from oil
and gas rigs and so forth.
And lastly, because Kubeflow
Pipelines is open source,
we actually have
a vast ecosystem
of partners contributing to it.
We have Intel that has--
as an example, Intel has
contributed components
to Kubeflow Pipelines,
particularly a component that
makes it easy to take models
and run them on Intel's OpenVINO
runtime.
And with that, I'd like to
pass things over to Willem.
WILLEM PIENAAR: Thanks, Aanand.
Hello, everybody.
My name is Willem and I lead
the data science platform
team at GOJEK.
So we're an engineering team
embedded within data science
at GOJEK, and our main focus
is building and implementing
the tools, the products, the
platform on which data science
and machine learning
operates at GOJEK.
So today, I'm going to be
talking a little bit about some
of the pains we had scaling
our data and email pipelines
and how Kubeflow Pipelines
helped us to address
some of those patterns.
So who or what is GOJEK?
GOJEK is an Indonesian
technology startup.
We were most famous for
ride-hailing on motorcycles,
but since launching that
product a few years ago,
we've branched into
many different products
and services.
So ride-hailing in cars,
food delivery with GO-FOOD,
logistics with
GO-BOX and GO-SEND,
digital payments with GO-PAY,
and many other lifestyle
services.
So today, we are in 15
different verticals,
and we have 19
different services that
mold up into one super app.
And there's one
singular goal, and that
is to solve every workday
need that you have.
So a little bit about our scale.
GOJEK is originally
an Indonesian company,
but we've now expanded
into Southeast Asia
and to many other countries.
The application has been
downloaded 125 million times
or more just in Indonesia alone.
One of our products, GO-FOOD,
is one of the largest food
delivery services in Southeast
Asia with over 400,000
merchants on the platform.
Like I said, we're in four
different countries right now--
Singapore, Vietnam, and Thailand
coming online in the last year.
Our ride-hailing service has
more than 2 million drivers
on the platform, hundreds
of thousands of which
are online at any
given point in time.
And we process more than 100
million bookings every month.
So the scale is quite large,
and the ability for us
to impact the company with data
science and machine learning
is quite great.
So I want to talk about
one of the first challenges
that we faced at GOJEK with
machine learning and data
science, and that was
finding the right driver.
It's a classic problem
in ride-hailing,
and that is dispatch
or allocation.
Which driver do you
send to a customer
when they want to
make a booking--
when they're making a booking?
So this is an important
question because of the amount
of transactions
that are processed
by a ride-hailing
company like GOJEK.
A system that
makes this decision
can have a very big impact on
the bottom line of the company
if you're looking at millions
of orders every month.
So this was one of the first
things the data science
team needed to solve, is build
a system that could decide which
driver to send to a customer.
And we originally started
with one North Star metric,
and that metric was conversion.
So what is the likelihood
that a successful trip will
be completed between
a specific pair
of a customer and a driver?
And so, when we set out
to build the system,
we looked at that
singular objective.
And then, as a data
science platform team
and as a data science
team, we came together
and we built the
systems that actually
could deploy this model
into a serving environment.
So we implemented airflow for
our data pipelines and machine
learning pipelines, and
we implemented Kubernetes
for our model serving.
The data scientists went to work
in building the pipelines that
transformed and
trained the models,
and they deployed
it into the serving.
And we integrated with the GOJEK
back end and it worked well.
The back end would send
us a list of drivers.
We'd re-route those
drivers according
to most likelihood
of converting,
and we'd choose the top
driver in most cases.
And there was an
uplifting conversion.
So we all thought it
was a job well done.
We made an impact
to the bottom line.
But it turns out that
our needs were greater
than that, greater than
just a single model.
And the thing we realized
was that machine learning
should provide many
levers to a business.
And in this case, we had
provided only a single lever,
and that was an
objective of conversion.
But actually, in a company
that does ride-hailing,
it's actually a marketplace.
So there's customers and drivers
meeting in this marketplace.
And there are many different
things you can optimize for.
You can optimize
for business metrics
like conversion, acceptance,
cancellation, costs or profit.
You can optimize for
the customer experience.
You can optimize for the
drivers' opportunities
and the fairness of assigning
the work because they're
ultimately employed, or at
least earning an income,
through this platform.
So we knew that we
needed to support
more types of objectives in our
system, not just conversion.
And we needed to be
able to experiment
in a more granular way.
So in a different
time and place,
we wanted to be
able to, let's say,
optimize for cancellation
and conversion
and, in another place, optimize
for the drivers' experience
or their opportunities.
So what we then decided to
do was improve our system.
Make this driver allocation
system a multi-objective system
that has many different
subcomponents,
many different models.
And then that would allow us
to, on a more granular level,
decide on a per-request basis,
what weighting of an objective
to rank these drivers on.
And this worked OK
for our serving layer,
because it's a relatively
small problem building
an ensemble hybrid
system like this.
But it turns out that taking our
existing pipelines in Airflow
and scaling it up
to meet the needs
of a generic, multi-market,
multi-service, multi-objective
system was actually
very, very difficult.
And it was difficult
for three key reasons
that I'll share with you now.
The first reason was it was very
difficult for us to experiment.
So the typical workflow
of a data scientist
is one of starting
in the notebook.
And they will do
their development
and then they'll get
up to a certain point
where they feel comfortable with
something that they've made.
Maybe they're training
a model and they
see some good performance and
they want to productionize it.
They want to get into
production because often,
with ride-hailing,
the only proven model
is once it gets into production,
not offline in a notebook.
So they're always keen
to get it into production
as quickly as possible.
And when you transfer this code
and rewrite it into Airflow,
one of the things that
happened in our experience
was that it became tightly
coupled to Airflow's
model of operators.
And so experimentation went
from the notebook to Airflow.
And Airflow is great at
doing data processing,
and it's really
meant for that use
case of transforming data
and updating partitions
in BigQuery or a
data store, but we're
talking about an ML use case.
We struggled to
scale up to the needs
of our multi-objective,
multi-market, multi-region
system.
So in the ML use case, you
want to quickly iterate
on your pipelines.
You want to quickly inject
configuration or data,
quickly add variance,
try TensorFlow or XGBoost
and see the results and
evaluate the results.
But this was very difficult
because of the fact
that Airflow's based on
chronological or time-based
runs meant for scheduling.
And so, variance within Airflow
was kind of tricky for us
to do.
And so, what ended up
happening is we had--
a lot of the workflows
were being forked,
and the graphs ended up
growing, and there was
a lot of duplication of work.
So the experimentation
was very tough for us.
The second problem
we had was there
was a lot of boilerplate
code being written.
And this was purely due to the
fact that the orchestration
layer--
the platform itself didn't
provide this abstraction
to the end user.
And so we knew that we needed
to solve this to allow the data
scientists to focus more
on, actually, the modeling
and what their specialty is.
And the third thing that
we were having a pain with
was traceability
and reproducibility.
So with our system,
we didn't have
a means of injecting
dependencies, so data
or configuration or
any kind of variance.
So what would end up
happening is the data
scientists would retrieve
these dependencies as side
inputs in their pipelines.
And these side inputs were
almost always untracked,
and it led to us having
very little reproducibility.
Because if we reran that
pipeline and those side inputs
had changed in the
meantime, then you'll
get different outputs.
So we knew we needed
a way to solve
this problem of side inputs
and untracked dependencies
in our pipelines.
And so, we looked at a
lot of the tools that
were available to us outside,
and we were already on GCP,
and one of the tools and
systems that we evaluated
was Kubeflow Pipelines
for this use case.
And the way we ended up
approaching and solving
this problem was as follows.
So for experimentation,
we introduced
Kubeflow for the ML pipeline
part of our data and ML
pipelines.
So we split our
pipelines into two.
We still use Airflow for
our data transformations
and publishing to
a feature store.
And this feature
store then becomes
the interface between
our ML pipelines
and our data pipelines.
So now, this has the effect
of allowing your ML pipelines
to be less data-focused.
Even though there's occasionally
some transformations there,
the pipelines are a lot smaller
and they run a lot faster.
And with Kubeflow
Pipelines, you can spin up
many different pipeline
instances, runs,
and you can inject
parameters into those runs.
And you can even do
it from a notebook.
So you can quickly do a
lot of experimentation
rapidly and compare these
results very easily.
And to reduce the amount
of boilerplate code,
we introduced
Kubeflow components
to our data scientists
and our users.
So these components are
pre-built by Google,
and a lot of them already exist.
You can use to use APIs or
Dataproc or any kind of systems
for common operations
that you can
do in your Kubeflow Pipelines.
But you can also offer
your own custom components.
And this allows us to,
as an engineering team,
abstract the users away
from common operations
like retrieving data
from phishers, stores,
or publishing to our
custom in-house deployment
environments or
anything like that.
So this is how we partly
solved some of the engineering
challenges and
abstracted those away.
And then, finally,
one of the key things
in Kubeflow Pipelines
that is very useful
is the parameterization
of the pipeline itself,
which was lacking in our
existing orchestration system.
So, by allowing
parameterization--
if you trace the
inputs to a pipeline
and if you track the actual
pipeline that executed it,
and if those inputs
are immutable,
then you'll
automatically get things
like traceability,
reproducibility,
and deterministic runs.
And this was one
of the key things
that we needed
because, if you're
tracking the metadata of
a pipeline and the model
that it produces
goes into production
and it performs well or
doesn't perform well,
you ought to be able to go
upstream again, and back,
and see why that was.
What led to that model
performing well or poorly?
But let's go to a quick
demo where I can show you
Kubeflow Pipelines in a
little bit more detail.
So this is the Kubeflow
Pipelines user interface.
And if you click on
the pipeline section,
it takes you to some of
the pre-built pipelines.
You'll see the sample
ones are the ones that
are just given to us when you
deploy Kubeflow Pipelines.
I've built one pipeline here
and deployed it already,
which we'll have
a look at shortly.
So these pipelines are
essentially templates.
They're not runs or pipelines
that are executed in the past,
but we can run them.
We can start them
as far as execution
runs with our parameters.
So I'm going to
click into this one
that I've built for allocation.
So this is a very simple
pipeline, a very simple example
to just illustrate how
Kubeflow Pipelines works.
So what you can see here is
multiple steps in a pipeline.
There are a few features
from the feature store,
a training of a model, the
building of a prediction set,
the evaluation of that set,
and then the publishing
of that depending on
the evaluation criteria.
So if you click into
one of these tasks--
one of these steps--
each step is a docker image
that will be run as a container.
So you can actually see, at the
bottom of this page, the docker
image that will be run.
So Kubeflow Pipelines
also tells you
which input parameters
will be sent to this step,
and how these inputs will
map to docker container.
So the fact that this
is a docker image that
will be run as a
docker container
means that development,
debugging, testing
is very easy.
You can do this--
all this actually
can be done in a way
that is completely
decoupled from Kubeflow itself.
And you also don't really
have any kind of lock-in
to Kubeflow.
So if you're moving from
Kubeflow to Airflow,
that process will be simple.
So, this example--
one more thing
that I wanted to
show you here is
that you can actually see
that the inputs map from one
task, one step into another.
And this specific graph has
been built both from a notebook
and published
previously, but I'll
go into a little bit
more detail later
in showing you how to
build this from a notebook.
So if you have a pipeline
already registered
with Kubeflow Pipelines, you
can create an instance of it
by clicking on Create Run.
So you can give your
pipeline run a name
and you can choose an
experiment, an experiment being
nothing more than a
grouping of comparable runs.
But for us-- and in terms
of the three problems
we had-- was rapid
experimentation being the first
and the third being
the traceability.
But the key thing
that we needed was
being able to inject these
parameters into our runs.
So this section is
really critical for us,
being able to
generalize our pipeline,
extract the complexities
and the things that change,
and create parameters from them.
And that allows us to more
easily scale to many markets
because we can have
parameters to define
service types or the region
where a specific pipeline
should be targeting.
And so these parameters
were really key for us.
So instead of looking
at these parameters,
I can actually show
you the notebook
that created this pipeline.
So if you click on the side
here on the Notebooks button,
it'll actually direct you to
a Jupyter instance running
in the same Kubernetes cluster.
So when you deploy
Kubeflow, it actually
deploys a Jupyter deployment
with that Kubeflow Pipelines
deployment.
And these two are able to
communicate with each other,
and it's a little bit more
abstract from the end user.
So if you click on
this pre-built notebook
that I have here for
us, I can walk you
through the process of creating
and authoring this pipeline.
So how this works
is you initially
start with some steps of
housekeeping and defining
some global variables, one
of which that is important
is defining your
Kubeflow SDK package.
And then, once
you have that URL,
you can just install it
with PIP so the installation
is super easy.
And then you're ready to go.
So the first thing
we do is we define,
or we connect this
Kubeflow client, this SDK,
to our local Kubeflow
Pipelines deployment.
It'll automatically find the
Kubeflow Pipelines deployment
if it's in the same cluster.
If it's in a remote
cluster or if you're
working on a local environment,
you need to specify a URL.
Then, you specify
an experiment name.
And this name, in
our case, will just
be allocation because that's
what we're trying to solve.
So this will just be a grouping.
And if you actually go back
to the experiments that
are available here, I've
already done some runs,
and there are some historic
runs already existing.
So the next step is
defining the pipeline.
This is the critical
part of actually using
Kubeflow Pipelines.
And there are basically
two steps to this.
The first is defining
the operations that
will be executed, and then
secondly is connecting those
up into a graph.
So what we do is--
I think what Aanand was
talking about earlier
is calling this
class of container
up and creating instances
of these operations.
And we parse in the
arguments that we
want to define as what
makes this operation unique.
And the two most important
parts here, which docker image
will be run and what will
be the arguments that we
send to that docker image.
And again, this makes debugging
and testing and development
very easy because you can
test the specific operation--
the step in your pipeline--
independently of Kubeflow
Pipelines.
You also need to give it
a name and just tell it
where output data will be
available once it's completed.
And we wrap this whole container
operation in a function call
because this makes
calling this, or creating
instances of this operation
later, a little bit simpler.
So in this case, we've got five
of these operations-- retrieval
of features, the
training of a model,
creating a prediction
set, and then
an evaluation step
with an RSC-curve,
and the publishing of the model.
Now, the most important part
is defining the pipeline.
So, here, it's nothing
more than a function call.
So we've just called
it Allocation Pipeline.
And the two important
parts here would be, first,
defining the input parameters.
And these arguments
to the function
call actually become
the parameters
that are available to you here.
So if you go back to the
pipeline that we've created
and you create a
run, these parameters
that are available
to you actually
come from the arguments
of this function call.
So this is great for
us in a lot of ways
because, often, we're
authoring these pipelines
and the end users
are not coders.
They're just maybe
business users or analysts
that just want to
do some analysis
or just explore what an
impact the model can have
and just experiment a bit.
So by publishing and compiling
this workflow into something
that can be deployed
to Kubeflow Pipelines,
end users can just use a
user interface and interact
with the system like that.
They don't need to
be able to code.
So then we decorate
this function
call with Kubeflow Pipelines
decorator, and give it a name
and a description, and
then, importantly, we
define the steps.
And here, we've got a
feature achievable step.
So we just call the function
we've defined already.
We specify the input parameters.
These input parameters
are the same ones
that are coming into
this function call.
And here's the important part.
The second step is
the training step,
and it depends on the
first step because you're
mapping the output
from the first step
into this second step.
So you're not actually
building the graph directly,
but you're specifying
inputs and outputs.
And once you've
completed these steps,
you can compile this pipeline,
and I'll do that right now.
So I've compiled this pipeline
and this allocation zip file
will be available in
this Jupyter environment.
And this can be
submitted to Kubeflow.
And once you've
submitted it, it'll
be available here as
part of your pipelines.
But a more interesting way
that we use Kubeflow Pipelines
is actually starting
the runs using
this allocation, or
this compiled pipeline,
from the notebook.
So the Kubeflow SDK--
the pipeline SDK allows you
to run a pipeline directly.
So you can specify experiment,
give your pipeline run a name,
specify the pipeline, and
then inject the parameters.
And this allows for that
rapid experimentation.
So in this case,
what I'm going to do
is I'm going to start a run.
And one of the parameters
will be a list of features
that we want to
send into that run.
And we've also got a
target of which objective
we're optimizing for.
So I can start a run here
and it'll create a little run
link for us, and I can delete
a bunch of these features.
And I can run that
again and now I've
got two runs that
are being executed.
I can imagine, if you want
to experiment very quickly,
you can have a four-loop there.
You can do a grid search
or parameter search.
You can spin up 100
pipelines if you want to
and compare them in
Kubeflow Pipelines.
So I'm just going to do this--
just sort of release
those features.
But if we go to
Kubeflow Pipelines
and we go to our
experiments, you
can see that there are
now two runs running here.
Click on one of these.
Feature retrieval
has already happened.
It's output a data set.
And you can see the input
and output parameters
through this step.
If you click on
Training, we can see
that this data
set's already been
loaded by the training set.
This is a specific
docker container
that's running inside of
this Kubernetes cluster.
And you get all the
benefits of Kubernetes
because it's running in
a Kubernetes cluster.
So as engineers, this
allows us to build platforms
on this existing tooling.
Click on the logs, you'll
see that training is already
running.
But for our use
case, I think I'll
show you some of the
previously executed runs.
So if you click on this run,
this is a completed run.
I can show you some
of the functionality
that Aanand was
speaking about earlier.
So one of the interesting
things that we can see
is, of course, the inputs
and outputs at each step,
but also the output artifacts
that are available to you.
So one of the output artifacts
that we have available to us
here is, at the
evaluation stage, or step,
is an RSC-curve.
So as an end user, you can
easily draw into this curve
and evaluate the performance
of the specific run.
But just doing this
on a single run
is not really that interesting.
It's useful, but a
more powerful way
to do this is to look at
multiple of these runs
together.
So we can actually click
on multiple of these runs
and compare them together.
And you can see that the
only thing that varies here
is the input parameters
of the list of features.
So here, we have
more or less features
for each of these runs.
Everything else is constant.
So what Kubeflow Pipelines
does is it actually shows you
the output artifacts at each
stage that has the same name,
but also shows you
an aggregated view.
So here, you get an
aggregated view of all three
of these runs.
So you as a user can draw into
the performance of these runs
and compare and contrast them.
So if you're spending
up many pipelines,
you can quickly compare them.
And even end users
that are not developers
can quickly compare them.
And some more of
the pipeline output
artifacts that I want
to show you is captured
in a TFX pipeline here.
So this is a bit more
of a complicated run.
It has more steps to it.
So this is using the
New York City taxi data
and it's a TensorFlow
model that it's training.
So some of the
other artifacts that
can be produced, for example,
is a confusion matrix.
So this matrix is
great for quickly
analyzing the classifier.
We've also got a table, which
is a very practical thing
to expose to end users.
You can just quickly
get a sample of data
and expose it to the end user.
They don't need to
open up BigQuery
or any kind of CSV file on GCS.
One of my favorite
output artifacts
is just a static HTML.
As an engineer, this
unlocks a lot of doors
because now we can embed
any HTML and JavaScript
and render anything within
Kubeflow Pipelines for our end
users.
All we need to do is
bolt the docker image
that produces this.
So in this case, the
end user can quickly
analyze the model itself
and just use this existing
static HTML and data set.
And then a more powerful
thing that Aanand
was showcasing
earlier is the fact
that we have tensor
boards available to us.
So at the training
step, we can actually
click on Open TensorBoard.
It's one of the artifacts
that's produced,
and the end user can then draw
into this and, in more detail,
analyze their model and the
specific TensorFlow run,
the distributions, histograms,
and anything like that.
So I'd implore you to have a
look at Kubeflow Pipelines.
And in fact, if we go
back to our presentation,
you can easily deploy a
Kubeflow Pipelines using
the deploy.kubeflow.cloud.
It's very simple.
It'll only take you one
or two minutes to do that.
And yeah, I encourage
you to give it a go.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]